(Teacher vocalizing)
We have to write an essay?
Five hundred words
about who we are?
I have no idea who I am.
Good grief.
You worry too much,
Charlie Brown.
WOMAN: Long before there was
a boy named Charlie Brown,
there was a man named
Charles Schulz.
Even as a kid,
I was cognizant of the fact
that there is a man
somewhere in America
who sits at a large,
slanted desk,
and he draws "Peanuts."
"Peanuts" is just
its own planet.
I related to Charlie Brown
so much.
I think Charlie Brown is just
a little bit of what all
of us have
inside of us.
My favorite character is Linus.
I used to carry around
a blue blanket.
Everybody knows what Lucy
with the football means.
Ugh!
I love Snoopy.
He is so cute.
(screaming)
SCHULZ:
Been dreaming about this thing
since I was about six years old.
PAIGE BRADDOCK:
He was the little kid
that no one really talked to.
(typing)
He was one person telling
a personal story every day.
Like all best creators,
there's a lot of himself
in the work.
I remember I called him
"my sweet Babboo."
Pretty soon it was
in the comic strip.
And he-- he was
those characters.
I have to figure out
the meaning of my life.
The meaning of life is
to give and receive love.
I feel like he always was
searching for the truth
and wanted
the world to be equal.
You saw the girls in sports,
which as a girl,
I'm like,
"Oh, that's great."
Here I am reading
this comic strip,
and all of a sudden,
there's a kid in there
that looks like me.
In was 1968,
papers threatened
to drop the strip--
And he was like,
"Fine, drop it."
The conversations
those young children have
resonates to our soul.
As successful as he was,
I don't know that he got
the full depth of the love
and devotion people had
to him and those characters.
SCHULZ:
Keep on trying.
Charlie Brown never gives up.
And if anybody should give up,
he should.
(chuckles)
♪♪ (theme plays)